over 40 years ago US President Richard
Nixon declared drug abuse public enemy
number one starting an unprecedented
global campaign the war on drugs today
the numbers are in the war on drugs is a
huge failure with devastating unintended
consequences it led to mass
incarceration in the u.s. to corruption
political destabilization and violence
in Latin America Asia and Africa to
systemic human rights abuses across the
world it negatively affected the lives
of millions of people all of this while
we waste billions of dollars every year
only to create and fuel powerful drug
cartels while the goal of the war on
drugs seems less achievable than ever
a world without drugs how could this
happen
the core strategy of the war on drugs is
no drugs no problems so almost all of
the efforts in the last few decades have
been focused on eradicating the supply
of drugs and incarcerating drug
traffickers but this ignores the most
fundamental of market forces supply and
demand if you reduce the supply of
anything without reducing the demand
first its price goes up this might lower
sales for many products look not for
drugs the drugs market is not price
sensitive drugs will be consumed no
matter what they cost so the effect is
to encourage production of more drugs
and recruitment of more traffickers
which increases availability this is
also known as the balloon effect even if
drug production or a major supply route
is destroyed the supply for the end user
is not reduced a perfect example of this
is crystal meth
the US government tried to stop its
production by strictly regulating the
sale of chemicals used to manufacture
the drug this forced big meth producers
out of business but the unintended
consequences were that thousands of
small-scale operations started all over
the country mostly in small towns and
rural communities using chemicals that
weren't regulated in response to this
some US states wanted to reduce the
supply of homegrown meth by regulating
even more chemicals which reduced
small-scale meth production drastically
but the supply of meth still stayed the
same Mexican drug cartels immediately
took over and opened big production
operations their meth was even better
than it was before and they had loads of
experience in smuggling so all these
efforts made meth production more
professional the drug more potent while
supply was introduced at all you can't
win this war on the supply side not only
our drugs widely available demand
unbroken and some drugs purer than in
the past
with a budget of around 30 billion
dollars the US Drug Enforcement Agency
has an efficiency rate of less than 1%
when it comes to stopping the flow of
drugs into the US and inside the u.s.
for many minors around the world it's as
easy to get illegal drugs as alcohol but
it doesn't stop here
prohibition may prevent a certain amount
of people from taking drugs but in the
process it causes huge damage to society
as a whole many of the problems we
associate with drug use are actually
caused by the war against them for
example prohibition makes drug stronger
the more potent drugs you can store in
as little space as possible the more
profit you'll make it was the same
during alcohol prohibition which led to
an increased consumption of strong
liquor over beer the prohibition of
drugs also led to more violence and
murders around the world gangs and
cartels have no access to the legal
system to settle disputes so they use
violence this led to an ever-increasing
spiral of brutality according to some
estimates the homicide rate in the u.s.
is 25 to 75 percent higher because of
the war on drugs and in Mexico a country
on the frontline an estimated one
hundred and sixty-four thousand have
been murdered between 2007 and 2014 more
people than in the war zones of
Afghanistan and Iraq in the same period
combined but where the war on drugs
might do the most damage to society is
the incarceration of nonviolent drug
offenders for example the United States
one of the driving forces of the war on
drugs has 5% of the world's total
population but 25% of the world's prison
population largely due to the harsh
punishments and mandatory minimums
minorities suffer because of this
especially african-americans make up 40%
of all US prison inmates and while white
kids are more likely to abuse drugs
black kids are 10 times more likely to
get arrested for drug offenses ok but is
there actually something different we
could do is there a way out of this mess
in the 1980's Switzerland experienced a
public health crisis related to heroin
use HIV rates skyrocketed and street
crime became a problem Swiss authorities
tried a new strategy harm reduction
they opened free heroin maintenance
centers where addicts would be treated
and stabilized here people would be
given free heroin of high quality they
would get clean needles and have access
to safe injection rooms showers beds and
medical subversion
social workers help them find housing
and deal with other problems in their
lives the results were a sharp drop in
drug-related crime and two-thirds of the
people in the centers got regular jobs
because now they could focus on getting
better
instead of financing their addiction
today over 70% of all heroin addicts in
Switzerland receive treatment HIV
infections have dropped drastically
deaths from heroin overdoses have
dropped by 50% and drug-related street
sex work and crime has been reduced
enormously so there are methods that are
not only way cheaper but also actually
work instead of creating more problems
drug prohibition led to a system that
bulldozes human rights costs vast sums
of money and creates a lot of human
misery all in pursuit of an unobtainable
goal after 40 years of fighting it's
time to finally end the war on drugs and
move on to something better this video
was supported by the Open Society
Foundations and by viewer donations on
patreon if you want to learn more about
how you can influence drug policy check
out the stop the harm campaign we
finally have some merchandise if you
want your own cuts cause out poster
t-shirt mug or stickers of little
monsters you can get them now at the
dftba store